alrighty so producer Colt and put
together some viral videos of me now I
will admit freely that I dislike
watching me but I'm going to do it
anyway and then I'm gonna comment on
these viral videos and give you my
reaction but first this video is
sponsored by bling so it's the
revolutionary invoicing software that is
going to allow you to keep track of all
the invoices you send now right now
you're probably making invoices on
Microsoft Word and then sending them to
people forgetting you ever sent them you
have no update you have no idea who's
paying the bills who's avoiding the
bells plus your invoices look like
garbage why not instead use a blink sale
blink sale makes all of these things
easy for you with blink sale you can
send a beautiful custom branded invoices
and estimates in seconds you can stay on
top of your outstanding invoices you can
let customers and clients easily pay
your invoices online and you'll even get
instant notifications when a customer
opens that invoice so you know who has
been dodging you forget about using
those invoicing templates instead use
blink sale calm forget about stressing
about coordinating a bunch of different
software programs instead check out
blink sale calm blink sale takes care of
all of these things for you as an added
bonus blink sale is doing something
magical and special for you they're
giving $10 away to 500 daily water fans
here's how this works
you go to blink sale calm you start your
14-day free trial you create your first
invoice of 10 bucks you activate an
online payment options there's stripe or
PayPal and send the invoice to daily
wire at blink sale com get paid your 10
bucks the first 500 people send that
invoice actually get $10 back all you
have to do is just send an invoice for
10 bucks your daily wire at bling sale
dot-com stop wasting your time traveling
sale for free right now at bling sale
calm / Ben that's bling sale calm / Ben
Bo I and K si le comm / Ben I bet my
name is Matthew and I go to the school
Catholic private school that is full of
leftist status punks and hate them and
like Alcoholics Anonymous meeting I tell
you so in the very rare case where a
leftist uses evidence logic and
empiricism how do i combat like
statistics they propose who is it and
when has it happened ever
[Music]
okay says it that way video okay seven
thug-life video so the dead life stuff
was one of the early sort of Internet
iterations of Ben Shapiro meme culture
I'm forever grateful to whoever is the
person who did this
it's really really funny because of
course I'm a nerd and so juxtaposing me
to these sort of I'm like wearing a tie
there right and then the thug life
culture it's pretty great I mean this
didn't become a Halloween costume for me
I believe you're one of the Ben Shapiro
show you can go back you can find the
episode where actually wore the the meme
Sutton the did gift sunglasses and and I
wore like a thug life hat and all the
rest of it but it's a source of endless
amusement even today to watch those kind
of things to the blunt come in from the
side so I I that stuff al sharpton say
hello to Ben Shapiro hi how are you have
you guys ever met or spoken before I
know I haven't and I'd like to just ask
mister Sharpton exactly why he's not
paying for the Tawana Brawley case and
also why he incited riots against using
Crown Heights there's another one of the
name culture that I remember this
specific episode of Keith Larson show so
I was friends with Keith I used to be on
his show weekly and we would just kind
of hash out the news for fifteen or
twenty minutes
this particular time I was scheduled to
call in and just at the time I was
supposed to call in then al Sharpton who
was then running for president called in
himself to be on Keith Lara sings this
in North Carolina and Keith says to me
off the air you know al Sharpton just
called in would you like to be on the
air with with Al Sharpton and I was like
okay this there's at least a half a half
a shot that this is actually just a
prank and this isn't actually all
Sharpton and then you can hear the
interview he starts talking to me I'm
like oh actually it is El shrapnel I'm
never gonna get on the / though Sharpton
again right there's never gonna be an
opportunity to be on the air with al
Sharpton again I was 19 at the time I
think 19 or 20 years old and and so I
said okay well now that I've got to ask
him a question I'm gonna ask the only
question that really matters about all
Sharpton which is why is he a terrible
person
al Sharpton did not actually have an
answer to this if you actually listen to
the rest of this particular interview
it's really funny because al Sharpton
threatens me with a lawsuit I say this
and he says you ask questions like that
and you could get sued
and then he and Larson have this broader
discussion and Larson comes back to me
says you have anything else to say to
Reverend Sharpton and I said not really
I just want to say to him that if he
feels like suing me for my $5,000 in Bar
Mitzvah money he can come right after me
any time mr. Sharpton and that was sort
of the end of the conversation so the
thug life began early is I think all you
can say about this then when you come on
television when you write columns do you
feel that that you are being persecuted
or do you feel that you are being you
know you know put in an uncomfortable
position because everybody else seems to
believe the opposite of what you believe
listen I'm happy to be in liberal areas
I've spent my entire life in a life in
Los Angeles in Cambridge Massachusetts I
like being in liberal areas I like
duking it out but there's no question
that the media is biased to the lefting
from the right on a on a left network
like CNN sure of course I'm on the
defensive and I go in a good game
planning for it I mean it's not the same
thing as going on Fox News which
obviously leans to the right I mean
there are for it I'm curious cuz we're
on you know the most meta show on CNN
how do you plan for it yeah but what I
do is I assume that I'm going to get a
certain set of questions from from folks
like you Brian that I generally do get
and with with with all the veiled
implications therein don't you feel
persecuted when you go on the left is
Network it the implication of course
being that I see myself as a victim
don't you feel like when you come on a
leftist network and you're being
attacked it then maybe it's because you
know you're just a little bit intolerant
these are usually the way these
conversations go so you know I'm glad
Brian that you haven't done all of those
things we've done some of them I'd
forgotten about that one that's a good
one that's some solid stuff there from
from Shapiro thug life so sometimes you
forget the good things that you've done
the good things that you've said I do
appreciate I can't remember who the
other guest is there in the split screen
but his reactions are pretty priceless
they're kind of valuable like you can
see he's trying not to laugh throughout
this entire conversation because indeed
it is it is quite ridiculous I mean the
truth is I've been on soldiers program a
few times and I've always found in me a
personable chap but one of the great
lies of course of CNN is its objectivity
and and brian Stelter as objective
journalist
not so much not so much so you've
supported like this really racist idea
that health care should not be for free
and I just wanted to ask about that
okay so here's how this works gang
honestly if you can't see that a
universal health care system is bad for
America you're wasting my time okay
okay folks so the health care cost
crisis didn't actually begin until the
government got involved by creating
Medicare and Medicaid because when you
artificially stimulate demand there's no
incentive to lower price not to mention
you are not entitled to the product of
somebody else's labor that's called
slavery gang okay this is what would
actually happen under a universal health
care system here's what a single-payer
health care system would actually do
okay folks it would actually make
doctors literal slaves who would have to
live in cabins on a plantation somewhere
all right folks and the idea and the
idea that doctors are just your slaves
you can you can you know marry without
their consent and then make half doctor
have regular people babies with okay
well then what happens to the babies are
they now doctors have a slave doctors
who have to be doctors are they free
look even now what King okay so that's
why that system would just never work
but but what I should just get health
care I should just get it for free
and that's how you talk to a leftist
[Music]
okay so now we have memes of memes right
we've got a meme of the thug life
I mean honestly there been a lot of
parodies made about me the only one I've
ever thought was actually deeply unfunny
the only parody I ever thought was
deeply unfunny was the one from our
cartoon president where Stephen Colbert
parodied me by having me holding hands
with Alex Jones that parody doesn't even
make sense like this one is obviously
taking my perspective on healthcare and
then taking it like way the hell out
there but it's funny I mean the
impression is funny and it's obviously
mocking my sort of trains of logic and
how I speak and then the way that I
break up my sentences and all of that
and so that stuff I find really really
funny because again it is a take-off on
my general perspective the freedom tunes
guys are really hilarious that the best
one of the freedom tunes by the way is
the the Thanksgiving dinner where it's
all versions of me sort of like back to
the future to where every character is
Michael J Fox and that particular
freedom tunes is my it is my favorite
I think I've seen this yes yes yes yes
yes yes yes this one is very funny yeah
I am waiting
haha that's epic
I'm literally laughing right now okay
I've seen this one I have not seen the
Sun okay question time how about we take
question from the girl with the pretty
hair what is going on what is this what
that okay I was just wondering when I
can't girls be in the Boy Scouts Oh
haven't you heard
I am already tracer oh yeah where is
that written
I'm the gamer rise up gamers this
society is no place for us
all hail Benjamin the only true God ok
this is epic
[Music]
you
yeah we're all valuable human beings but
all was restricted to the tribe for most
of human history and we are reverting
back to that now which is all you know
we are all valuable except for that guy
that guy's not valuable screw that guy
right he's a member of an opposing tribe
and I think that that's not only a
problem I think that that takes the
heart out of a society there are
legitimately millions of people in this
country who believe that I will go to
hell because I don't believe in Chinese
visas and you know what I think about
that I'm a ball of meat wandering
through the universe purposeless I don't
have very well I don't have the capacity
to to control my own life what am I
supposed to do now take my arm in and
put a knife in it and stab you well
maybe we should like think about what
the actual possible downsides here are
because virtually every action that we
take has some unintended content I have
a duty to kill you
wait hold on a second you have no
evidence whatsoever that that is the
case I'm here to kill you what do you
even care like why can't you leave me
the hell alone I'm gonna say what is
what I think is true here and we're done
and love Dave Rubin yeah yeah you know
what I think about that I don't care
that's fine money I don't care I think
it's good so that's a lot of me and
that's a lot of fake me and I very much
look forward to Media Matters taking
those quotes from this butchery of
everything I've ever said and then
trying to come after me to to cancel
this that did medicine salad stuff
actually I'll admit the better version
of this is Jordan Pederson debating
Jordan Peterson from from Dave's show
that that one is definitely the better
version of this although it's it's
enjoyable and I have seen the the Ben
Shapiro versus Shen but you look at
stuff before and the fact that I'm a
meme is of utter amusement to me because
again I am probably the squareness
person on planet earth so the fact that
I've become part of this sort of meme
culture is endlessly hilarious well
thanks for watching this and I'm sorry
next time we'll do something radically
different that I'm sure you will enjoy
even more than you didn't enjoy this one